president Trump is in Jerusalem this
morning on the second leg of his first
foreign trip in office right now he is
speaking with the Israeli president in
Jerusalem these are live pictures Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu greeted the
President and First Lady Melania Trump
after Air Force one landed in Tel Aviv
before the formal welcoming ceremony the
two leaders joked about it to each other
little presidential protocol jokes there
the President and First Lady will visit
the Church of the Holy Sepulchre in
Jerusalem on the site where Christians
believe Jesus was buried
they will also visit the Western Wall
making him the first sitting president
to visit
Judaism's holiest site mr. Trump said
this morning that new opposition to Iran
improves the chances of bringing peace
to the region what's happened with Iran
has brought many other parts of the
Middle East toward Israel and you could
say that's one of the if there's a
benefit that would be the benefit
because I've seen such such a different
feeling toward Israel from countries
that as you know were not feeling so
well about Israel not so long ago
President Trump spent the weekend in
Saudi Arabia in a speech the president
urged leaders from dozens of Muslim
majority countries to aggressively fight
terrorism
Susan pages USA TODAY's Washington
bureau chief good morning good morning
so so far how do you assess the
president as president versus the
president has candidate you know it's
interesting we were looking at this trip
thinking maybe it would be a debate
between President Obama and President
Trump it's really between president
Trump and candidate Trump because boy
did we see that yesterday in that big
speech in Saudi Arabia about Islam What
did he say during the campaign Islam
hates us he called for a ban on all
Muslims yesterday he talked about all
face working together this is not a war
between religions a totally different
tone it's amazing because the
speechwriter was what Steve Miller said
well I think Steve Miller got some
revisions on this one is this reflected
also the tone of Rex Tillerson and a
general McMaster and others who have
come in and tried to adjust actually
what Rex Tillerson said this morning on
the flight to Tel Aviv was that
the president's views on Islam continue
to evolve remark which is remarkable to
hear a secretary of state describe the
president's position is evolving you
know it's something that might be seen
as kind of patronizing typically in
admin administration but that is in fact
what we see happening on this run and on
others he's in he's in Israel now you
know during the campaign he promised to
move the US embassy to Jerusalem a big
issue in Israel that has not happened it
gives you an Arab countries - yes
exactly and that's why it hasn't
happened yet but in perspective Susan on
how big this was you know there's a
popular song had a bad day last week
they had a bad week some people even use
word catastrophic how big is this for
president Trump this week you know the
first big foreign trip would be big for
any president but this one is especially
crucial because he's coming off what I
think is the most catastrophic week for
a president in memory you know it's just
a week a week ago today that we found
out that he had talked to the Russian
leaders in the Oval Office and revealed
intelligence it turns out to be from
Israeli intelligence sources and then we
have a series of other things happening
including the disclosure that there's
someone a senior official in the White
House that is a person of interest in
this investigation of meddling with
residues I I don't know the answer that
question is a list of three people we
might suspect well there might be but
there I don't know enough about that to
even say that out loud on your show just
speculate out loud well said yeah very
well you know what is the other
remarkable thing about this trip no
press conferences so far and no tweeting
by the President and what's most
remarkable the White House sees this as
a huge achievement that this that this
trip has stayed on message because the
president has answered questions because
he hasn't said any of those provocative
tweets now here's the question they've
done that for three days can they do
that for nine days yeah
well the president was said when he
realized it was nine days tried to
shorten it but that's right people sorry
yeah and in the people around the White
House people in the White House now say
the president's been really let's give
him the benefit of all the doubt that he
would like us to I mean what has he
accomplished here and what may he
accomplished that will perhaps set in
motion some kind of grand bargain well
you know it's it's possible this is a
you know it's not that like we've had so
much great success in reaching a Middle
East peace under one approach this is a
somewhat different approach the
president says
is a moment in time where it might be
possible to have a fresh start on an
israeli-palestinian a quarter of course
we all hope that happens right start a
better word than reset isn't it yeah we
said has a history Susan page always
good to have you here thank you so much